hi everybody it's multiple players I'm
you're just slightly distracted but now
totally on point host Chris waters and
me it's my slowly distracted and maybe
not so annoyed co-host Marrakech yeah I
we're playing crap robot roller derby
disco dodgeball there's so many robot
roller derby disco dodgeball there's so
many vowels it's the double our Triple D
and we're playing right now so you can
join us if you want to it's all the
games on Steam you can grab it and then
just search go to find match and go to
room 2 2 3 3 there yeah that's our
that's our room and get [ __ ] disco
dodgeball with us we've already got a
couple folks in the in the game
including i believe the developer at
least he'll be here shortly Eric
asmussen he's also in the twitch chat so
join us there for fun chatting at mouse
sensitivity la mery get yours to get
your settings right these mary has never
played this game so important oh yeah
take that disco Robbie so basically if
the name says it all there are robots
it's a roller derby because they're all
on no that's not that's my teammate
they're all on a nice drive unit cycles
they're like unicycle robots with
moustaches like see this guy's got half
shade I have whiskers you got whisked
like walrus whiskers what kind of
whiskers like to be shown cat whiskers
and basically you just roll around this
whole spot and you can like jump just
roll around for out and really know and
then you get yet dot is dodge ball you
throw dodgeballs I cannot bat chuck him
do you remember the five thunderbolt
dodge ball if I don't what are the 5 d's
of dodgeball dodge duck dip dive and
dodge all teams are full dang it didn't
like it I want a spectate lost before he
could even join yeah dude own show oh
cuz i can use a few tips alright if you
hold down this fire key charge up a shot
uh uh uh and that'll it'll sort of go
did you just block that with your ball
quickly vanquished yellow sanchez all
right oh it's about here there's only
two more I guilt oh wow Mary coughing up
the penultimate kill down the other two
ago yeah match loss next match I'll get
away from me Sanchez demon oh no I got
thrilled by the developer gosh this wash
runner right let's get out the winning
and losing quick just press ready so you
at least get it thank you can what is
this what are you menacing at me there
easter egg oh is it Easter candy Oh is a
bad choice every time you lie to you
every time you leave yet
you just brought in the crap Easter can
you don't actually want to eat didn't
you I think that's the cat can you bring
into work the stuff you don't actually
want to eat yourself I didn't think this
through Oh snagged it what a catch what
a catch catch no I got hit for losing
death all right losing me death these
folks reason they're like to eat the
easier I think it's a multi dodge ball
ball they're delicious uh Oh God now
it's crumbly can you hear the pain yes
your candy facebook with disco oh it's a
pretty close game it's eight to nine
first to 25 feel like you have new
middle
oh I got him or her and then I got paid
doback to man noble kill oh no someone's
on the tail they're on my tail Oh God
ma'am to it match lost Oh stroyed you
know nothing about dodgeball all right
that's a nice yellow Peggy wish you
didn't eat them and you didn't have to
before I didn't i befriend yellow bitter
pill of defeat all right welcome all
right we have to be Oliver's another
miss our chance to get into the actual
none I've certainly don't know what that
means an arrow advantage oh my god it's
absolute pandemonium protect oh yes I'll
hold the ball you got to hold the yellow
ball cuz it's the super bowl got it whoa
hey guys I got the thing sometime motion
all ebrake oh yeah dave king st. 1818
think p thief to me the no is it auto oh
yeah damn right on the tail no
I protected him with my body you did
that was not one of you that I'd like
throw my way from downtown I'm all Wow
sacrificial lamb care to me mmm playing
my body down the good of the team this
is the important it's important to make
whole book sounds great not you what oh
no I've been hit Matt win all right
let's see game server you guys lost
chasm he said all right oh yeah we're
gonna have big tummy aches after this
live stream where's the person he's over
here
yellow Sanchez is on fire to be fair
he's he's gone too far he must be
exterminated really know your steal it
from me no I'm just gonna stand in front
of you you're such a brat we're gonna
get out of a where is the mail yeah
where's the mail it's much oh no let's
show what a choke you know that's how
they'll remember you Chris waters what a
choke it Oh what you're on fire what is
you set me on fire I did with my fire
smiley whispers I feel like then no
matter who wins you should eat me sir
wait a minute cuz I really don't want to
eat it it would still be a real hero for
this team I personally would really like
to not cut any anymore maybe you should
reflect that in your gameplay oh no oh I
look down you can see your own wheel oh
that's adorable yeah you picked it up
like you're gonna just squat from the
whole chalice know what there's
something called a chest bump i may add
a male a button that smacks of all out
of enemy hands says eric the developer
in the chat can you add a button that
makes Mary not regret her decision so
badly I understood with regret jump nope
all right come on you guys humping come
on we have to win this I literally
cannot eat another egg you hear the
desperation in her going on that is not
faked come on that is for real like
trepidation and agony come on you guys
we got it we got it we got it
I through my body nice kill Barry nice
work somebody do something I'm not
eating anymore that eye candy I can't do
it then we does need one more point get
it for like one second get it getting
into getting it here I come here come
here come uh-huh no no I don't have a
ball somebody do something have your
sucha I'm not eating another easter egg
this can't happen no no no no no no no
no no no I missed the shot get it no you
sinister aren't well done well done
everybody I'm so sick of me yet a bomb
capsule from Eric are what I colored can
you see the speckling on this is just
beautiful all right uh we're gonna take
a quick break we'll be back we'll set up
a different kind of match and we'll see
how this this goes see you guys in a sec
no
oh I was worth it if I eat candy nobody
died no it's nobody let them get to the
checkpoints oh yeah most death six been
huntin seem like a lot that seems like
like a note uh-huh wait do we have to do
the thing are you gonna are you gonna
make us do this again Mary that is the
rule giggles uh I got it in the face
dangit Sheen rocks protect why do we
have to protect because he's gonna throw
it through this oh there's one specific
ball it's not like the yellow ball come
on oh oh what I [ __ ] bouncing off the
rim oh I'm disappointed in me yes how
much that's worth damn it Mary nothin
nope Oh going for her sweet victory oh I
blasted him just too late dagnabbit
eaten for Jimmy
not if I have anything to say about it
with that terrible bow shot what I am
the worst shot why would anyone ever
happy all their team all right red team
we're doing spec terribly denied Kyle I
don't think so Kyle
oh yeah I hit that [ __ ] good Ally
crappy crop the math team I've got can
use crafty where where we and now we
don't have to drink any more of these
wonderful candy what time for a victory
candy cuz you know no more candy I'll
clean that I've got that process it
perfect action the candy oh that's robot
roller derby disco dodgeball ladies and
gentlemen thank you for watching the
stream thanks for playing this was
really fun we don't always use sometimes
it's playing on the couch Iran multiple
players sometimes we play get to play
with you guys out there so if you're in
the action if you enjoyed that just like
tweet at us and let us know if you're up
for a future multiplayer games mm-hmm
unless your name is Kyle or yellow
Sanchez in which case you're too good
we're not that good uh Mary thanks for
playing yeah thanks for having me that's
fun Oh candy war I'm gonna be sick oh ah
next week multiple players on at the
same time if you have ever endings have
any suggestions for games this one
actually was a user suggestion so keep
them coming and I will see you tomorrow
for 11am with Sean and then 2 p.m. the
lobby it's gonna be awesome we'll see
you guys that bye
you